ich finde es wirklich eine frechheit
wenn autoren so was wohl eher schon der
titel war super pit angeles simon oder
simone lauper 2 schatten
ja was ich wirklich nicht vertrage ist
diese art von esoterischer ich bezogener
literatur die nur noch sich mit
hermetischen innerlichkeit befasst die
sonst niemanden interessieren und dann
ging es da um eine schauspielschülerin
die auch so nahmen hatte wie ah da ist
alles und julia de die in diesem buch
das liebe ich auch schon immer wenn
diese namen haben es ist auch eine frage
nach identitätssuche wer bin ich und wo
gehöre ich hin und das ist sehr gut
dargestellt
es ist eigentlich wurscht worum es geht
in büchern es geht darum wie es
dargestellt wird oder bei itunes zu mir
sie beides ist richtig es ist kein gar
nichts passieren an äußerer handlung
wenn es gut dargestellt oder was er
verloren hat in einer gesellschaft
genaueres kameras oder auf telenovela
die wohl machen
ich möchte charaktere die innerlich
irgendwie eine brechung aufweisen weil
das einfach im leben nicht so ist dass
wir nur abziehbilder sind aber es ist
doch ein moment des scheiterns wo sie
einfach da steht und nicht vorwärts
kommt und nicht so sei so ein kit stufen
das plus wohnung nicht verlassen
nein das war es nicht es war ein sehr
und wir in der jury um dieter bohlen zum
glück möchte ich sagen nie wieder etwas
gehört
die hat nämlich sechs jahre sechs jahre
gebraucht wenn dieses buch was glaube
ich ungefähr 120 seiten hat sich ja
enorm zum vorwurf dass er lange ich bin
froh weil sie schäden sollen sie bitte
80 jahren ist das buch brauchen warten
je nachdem wie lange ich hier noch sitze
um sich zu überzeugen
ich sage nichts mehr